les chéris matthews avait un coup de
griffe oui parce que contre que thierry
ardisson que j'ai vu dans l'émission
complément d'enquêté
et ce qui m'ennuie c'est que thierry
ardisson c'est un peu comme michel cymes
aujourd'hui c'est pas un animateur c'est
un mercenaire
c'est à dire qui va effectivement au
plus offrant et il change d'avis
complètement dès qu'il ya un peu
d'argent alors ce garçon pendant des
années a critiqué service public c'est
ringard c'est vieux est arrivé en canal
sur canal en dix ans pendant 13 ans sur
canal j'ai jamais été aussi heureux
c'est la liberté d'expression ça me
ressemble et maintenant qu'il a été viré
du groupe canal au passage il a pris
huit cent mille euros mais qu'il a été
viré du groupe en procès maintenant il
dit france télévisions j'aimerais bosser
avec eux c'est la vraie liberté
j'ai jamais été aussi libre que sur
cette chaîne c'est une chaîne qui est
drôle
elle me ressemble et se fait jour dans
l'eau elle me ressemble
voilà et je trouve ça hallucinant
manrique les appels du puy affronter
illusion menant qu'il a plus de boulot
chaîne sur laquelle il a craché pendant
15 ans et il a été viré je le rappelle
et voilà et maintenant il n'y a pas de
mémoire en télé c'est comme ça qu'il ya
bien voir ja pardon avec madame ernotte
il va avoir un problème parce qu'elle
dit qu'elle veut pas d'animateur de plus
de 50 ans voilà veut pas d'homme n'est
pas dieu non pas de weeds en c1 c'est
vrai il ya tout le des femmes et déjà
vous est-ce que voilà vous est-ce que
vous avez des critiques est vraiment une
chaîne à mon bon vraiment voilà vous
êtes dit benjamin cadet non jamais
d'abord parce que je ne croyais pas je
n'aime pas vous avez craché sur ces 8
jamais de la vie non aucun des deux j'ai
dit que si elle était un tyran critique
c'est la vérité j'étais là c'est la
vérité le spectacle
j'occupe depuis deux ans le portable
parce que là la toile s'améliore à les
en croire mais c'est vrai on va pas se
mentir
tu as juste voulu faire un bouquin pour
prendre un peu d'oseille était une
connerie dans son bouquin dit les choses
maintenant benjamins es ce que tu ne
cesse d'appeler un jour il a mal parlé
jeudi je vais défoncer voilà c'était mon
cas n'est pas tyrannique tu travaillais
pas avec moi il rejette la nouvelle star
et tu refusais devant l'allemand a dû
briser mes bouquins que je vais vous
raconter l'histoire c'était avant
j'étais chez pas quoi je me suis
embrouillé avec lui chez même pas
pourquoi j'ai entendu qu'il avait mal
parlé moi je l'appelle au téléphone
jeudi je vais trouver je vais te
défoncer voilà c'est tout et après on a
fait l'option libre messieurs
je trouve que critique et enfin ceux qui
vous ont nourri ce truc qu'on ne connaît
bien sûr tu as raison mais c'est moi je
n'ai jamais fait tf1 j'ai bossé pour
condamner j'ai bossé pour ses 8 je ne
sais pas peut toujours penser vite je
suis prêt à bosser pour s'est vite voilà
et c'est vrai et je trouve ça chez refn
tâche avait craché sur eux n'ont pas là
c'est pas bien et traitement sauf que
dans ce métier sa part m6 a des hauts et
des bas on parlait bien sûr tu as raison
ça se fait pas aux mêmes enjeux que
c'est un comportement je suis un peu
d'accord à dire que lesdits j'ai un peu
d'accord est un peu gonflé et a beaucoup
critiqué tf1 que dante et bmp
non je critique où les phoques destinera
en train de taper sur tf1 entend bien et
alors je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec vous mais j'ai toujours été 2 h
pour objecter avec tf1 l'ancien maillot
objectif quand tout à l'heure il dit
voilà il dit qu'il aime pas l'émission
c'est parce qu'il n'aime pas et moi je
voudrais de téléphone des fêtes furax de
ce qu'ils ont vu à l'intérieur sur mis à
l'antenne
moi je suis souvent se met à la place de
séparer ces n'a rien contre eux tu es
j'ai rien contre la lèvre watch hrw a de
grandes chaleurs franchement devenir moi
ma honda on m'a reproché de de critiquer
koh lanta j'ai toujours dit que
j'adorais colonies d'alors comme après
il ya des saisons que j'ai aimé plus que
d'autres après un moment ça peut me
souhait mais c'est vrai qu'on voit la
vie autrement